bonsoir je vais vous demander quelque
chose d'un tout petit peu extraordinaire
je vais vous demander de vous lever
je vais vous demander de vous lever et
de sentir vos pieds dans le sol
vos pieds s'enfoncent dans le sol comme
les racines d'un arbre et votre tête
telle la sim peut aussi émouvant la tête
monte vers le plafond comme un ballon
d'hélium
les bras sont relâchés comme des lianes
sur les épaules
les pièces ancre dans le sol la tête
monde ferlo est la colonne vertébrale
ces tirs et puis comme un papillon
une main se dépose sur le sternum et une
autre sur le bas ventre et simplement
vous entendez le coeur qui bat et la
respiration qui aussi et puis tout aussi
calmement je vais vous demander de
fermer les yeux
un petit moment pour soi une vigilance
détendu à soi retrouver le calme
cette zone au plus profond de soi
puis lentement les mains vont glisser
pour aller chercher celles qui sont à
côté
lentement vous allez trouver la main à
droite et la main à gauche et puis vous
allez donner de la présence à ses mains
vous allez un peu serré les mains un peu
sentir qu'on est ensemble dans cet
espace un peu sentir qu'on habite ici
vous sentez l'énergie qui circulent vous
sentez la force du lien vous sentez
cette force tranquille que cela nous
procure en fait c'est ça l'essentiel de
mon travail de pédagogue du mouvement et
l'exercice est terminé merci vous disais
c'est ça l'essentiel de mon travail de
pédagogue du mouvement que je mène au
sein de l'association mouvance qui est
un groupe d'action et de réflexion sur
la danse notre principal outil où notre
principal objectif c'est de générer du
lien c'est dire je plusse jeu plus de
plus je plusse jeu égal nous chacun à sa
place
chacun a sa force le new que je vous
propose ici se définit ici et maintenant
dans l'action se noue est un réseau
c'est à dire des interconnexions se
nouent et comme un mouvement
il existe et puis il n'existe plus il et
circonstanciée chaque jeu est singulier
chaque personne qui est dans ce groupe
et singulière nous avons tous le corps
en commun mais tous nous sommes
différents nous ne sommes pas ce qu'on
indéfinie et malhonnête qu'on voudrait
bien nous faire croire
nous ne sommes pas cette masse
indifférenciée et englobante le nous que
je vous propose ici se définit ici et
maintenant et peut s'assumer estimé sa
force son pouvoir d'action son pouvoir
créateur se noue se construit sur du
commun tout autant que sur la
différenciation de ses membres nous
tenons ensemble d'une certaine façon
nous nous
tenons ensemble dans cet espace nous
habitons le même monde
nous sommes solidaires une des première
conquête de la démocratie d'ailleurs
c'est ça le droit de s'associer
la démocratie c'est liberté égalité
solidarité liberté de dire égalité de
droit solidarité du nous c'est dire le
droit au nous à nous au pluriel car
c'est aussi la possibilité de se
dissocier de ne pas être d'accord de
débattre d'être en conflit
par exemple dans une improvisation
collective en danse chacun peut proposer
un mouvement et tous les autres
improvisateurs peuvent décider de suivre
de contrastes et de mettre en évidence
de contredire d'influencé de se laisser
influencer
c'est la liberté de dire oui ou la
liberté de dire non se nouent au pluriel
c'est aussi la possibilité d'
appartenance multiples je suis partie
prenante de plusieurs nous je suis
artiste en mouvement je suis artiste en
voit parfois je suis gourmand voir
insatiable je suis professeur humaniste
je suis gestionnaire enthousiaste je
suis animateur en gestion de conflits et
pour chacun la liste est longue
chacun peut revendiquer son identité
multiple
nous avons le droit de dire nous nous
avons deux le droit c'est à dire que
nous avons la possibilité mais alors
pourquoi nous le faisons nous pas tous
pourquoi ne sommes-nous tous pas
citoyens comment passer de la
possibilité à l'action en fait je crois
que c'est ça l'objectif que je me suis
fixé que nous nous sommes fixés au sein
de l'association mouvance être des
catalyseurs des gens qui favorise
l'action qui favorise l'expression du
pouvoir créateur que nous avons tous la
première chose c'est de susciter l'envi
l'envi de s'exprimer de prendre part à
une création collective d'entrée en
mouvement de bouger de réhabiliter
l'espace commun de ré habiter l'espace
public
cette photo c'est un souvenir de
territoire nomades une performance que
j'avais fait dans une galerie
commerciale à charleroi
et puis je suis revenu faire ici à reims
lors du parking des et cette photo elle
me fait dire que pour susciter l'envi il
faut se mettre au diapason du regard de
l'autre
il faut aller chercher dans sa
singularité ensuite
parallèlement il s'agit de donner des
outils des clés lecture des langages
pour dire et débattre il s'agit de
parler de la même langue le corps à ce
site génial qu'il est universel
si je fais ceci ou si je fais ceci vous
percevez tous la différence et ce
faisant je joue simplement sur le tonus
musculaire
un des paramètres du mouvement
j'investis ou non mon mouvement
j'investis ou non ma pensée investi ou
non ma volonté
le corps ne ment pas vous vous souvenez
de ce moment au début où je veux
demander de serrer les mains vous
souvenez-vous de la force tranquille que
ça vous a donné de cet esprit du lien
que cela a généré lao tseu a dit un jour
donner du poisson à un homme il mangera
un jour apprenez lui à pêcher il mangera
toute sa vie et c'est bien de cela qu'il
s'agit aussi ici donner des outils puis
autonomiser les créateurs c'est à dire
les accompagner dans leur envol les
accompagner dans la mise en pratique de
ces outils
donc pour passer de la possibilité à
l'action nous proposons de générer du
lien susciter l envie donner des outils
puis autonomiser le créateur nous
proposons de le faire par le corps nous
proposons de répondre au défi du vivre
ensemble par les corps parce qu'elle
relie à l'intuition parce que le corps
ne ment pas parce que nous l'avons tous
en commun et je refuse
cette espèce de guillotine ambiante qui
placent souvent l'intellect comme seule
façon de construire le vivre ensemble
je suis convaincu que nos démocraties
ont tout à gagner à incorporer le vivre
ensemble à l'éprouver par le corps pour
le faire rejaillir au quotidien pour que
la démocratie devienne un art de vivre
et pas juste une façon de penser merci